por supuesto que esta hazaña del real
madrid tenemos que analizarla a la luz
de la figura de un hombre como carlo
ancelotti que tanto podemos atribuirle a
él de este resultado la verdad es una
pregunta muy interesante porque en
tiempos en los que tanto club guardiola
o to hell' dominan como este escenario
dialéctico de lo que es el entrenamiento
y la táctica en el fútbol hoy por hoy
aparece una figura como la de carlo
ancelotti y reaparece no sólo de la
manera convencional como suele decirse
no como un entrenador que lidera o
gestiona muy bien el vestuario sino que
es un entrenador que a partir de una
renovación de su cuerpo técnico y
dándole mucha relevancia a la
especificidad del trabajo logre este
resultado creo que es un entrenador que
tácticamente lo que le genera son
escenarios en los que los jugadores
pueden realizar una toma de decisiones
muy natural y esto ha potenciado este
equipo evidentemente dominaron desde la
jornada 3 fueron líderes de la liga
española y esto se ha notado también en
la capacidad que tienen de superar la
adversidad este título es muy relevante
para el real madrid y para carlo
ancelotti después de que estuvo unos
años fuera de ese foco de la élite o de
la gran élite pero recordemos que es un
entrenador con más de 27 años de
experiencia más de 20 títulos tres
champions league y es el único que ha
ganado en las cinco grandes de europa
ganó con el bayern ganó con el chelsea
galo con el milan con real madrid con
parís saint germain esto habla de la
calidad de entrenador y creo que ahora
pasamos al siguiente tema que es nos va
a dar un muy buen partido de champions
league